imagine the single best tasting beer you
ever had
now imagine that every beer since then
has tasted exactly the same what's the
point
Schaefer people get that consistent
great taste because Schafer's bad at
first Schaefer beer is more than three
years old but if you think that's an
old-school beverage how about this beer
was brewed in ancient Egypt in fact it's
been around for more than 10,000 years
we met up with an archaeologist who's
not only discovering its sudsy origins
he's actually recreating ancient ales
that you can consume today Travis ruff
leads two rather different lives in
Boulder Colorado in the Greek world
oftentimes relief sculpture was very
much focused on mythology one as an
adjunct professor of classics art
history and anthropology at the
University of Colorado the other as a
beer archeologist at Avery brewing or
more specifically George title here is
what is innovation and would seller
manager and beer archeologist rep says
it's really two hobbies a love of the
classics and a love of beer which turned
into two jobs one that didn't really
exist until Rupp and Avery brewing
created it are there any other beer
archeologists out there that you know of
not necessarily no I know of a few other
scholars that work in the field of
ancient beer I'm the only one that works
for a brewery recreating these ancient
beers
how far back does beer date that is a
fantastic question it's an ongoing
debate potentially 13,000 years ago they
were making beer
the ancient Romans had no word for beer
there is no word for beer in Latin
there's no Greek word for beer either
but they defined the alcoholic beverage
by whatever the locals called it from
the location it came from and it was
beer it's the first craft beer yeah yeah
exactly it is the first craft beer well
the professor wanted to learn the brewer
wanted to taste I think part of it was
that homebrew mentality with home
brewing it was always experimentation
when you start looking into the textbook
sometimes they'll talk about alcohol
that was drank by a pharaoh or an
emperor or something like that and it's
always wine wine wine wine except the
Egyptians who tend to talk quite a bit
about drinking beer and so I got really
curious I wanted to learn more about the
average job so RUP set out on a path to
recreate the beers that an average Joe
of the past may have been drinking and
that's where the longtime home brewer
leaned on his professorial background
formulating the first of Avery brewings
ales of antiquity and to dig into the
textbooks in different ways physically
travel to the locations where we've
recreated the beers look at the modern
culture and then start working our way
back to the past what was readily
available for people to use all the time
of these ingredients what about these
two these two though our ancient greens
that we used as some of the antiquity
these are actually wheat so as opposed
to barley wheat Rupp offered up his
first we creation in August 2016
an ancient Greek beer about 3,300 years
old called Nestor's cup the public
response was amazing I mean I started
getting calls from local museums and
being asked to put on dinners to talk
about this whole process of recreating
it so you'd created this ancient Greek
beer and people heard about it yeah
wanted to taste it because they thought
it was good or thought how bad might
this be great question I think honestly
they were just really curious to see
what it tasted like and had very very
low expectations for it honestly so did
I
that's really good sweeter than my dog
yeah so this was a combination of mostly
wild yeast it also has a corns in it and
then elderberries and figs which gave it
this deep purple color
Nestor's cup led to seven more ales of
antiquity over the past three years from
ancient Peruvian beer Pachamama
to a thousand-year old Viking beer
called Ragnar x' drop ax and what are
the most popular ancient ales Beersheba
with roots in Israel Palestine and
Jordan this is about 300 BC again really
roughing Avery brewings most recent beer
George Washington Porter released in
February his first American offering no
matter the origin
RUP says there's a common challenge when
it comes to taste I can't get a kernel
that's 4,000 years old it's gonna taste
exactly like that so I have to get as
close as I can as for why the general
public is buying into the past it makes
it more tangible to them makes the the
ancients very similar to them in some
ways and for up that's more than enough
reason to keep toiling away at both of
his jobs as a lover of history
archaeology and I'm also an educator and
I love to give people an experience my
goal is to preserve history they help me
preserve that history by drinking it and
we can help preserve that history okay
by tasting the porter while you guys
taste I'm gonna say this they don't have
them canned and available for
distribution right now it's only at
Avery Brewing but they're working on
that aspect so popular though that
they've already sold out of two of the
kinds that he's made he made eight
different types to kegs are sold out one
they'll finish next weekend and then
they'll work on making even more I love
that you brought free sample yes I do
surprisingly good right and that's what
sort of was amazing and again some of
these kernels you can't get one that's
4,000 years old he goes as closest he
can figure out to what they were using
what was your favorite a mix I really
like the Beersheba a lot